وهذا فقط في شبكة CNN ، اضطر راكب
على متن طائرة تابعة لشركة الخطوط الجوية الأمريكية من
نيويورك إلى دالاس إلى النزول من الطائرة
بعد رفضه ارتداء قناع أريد أن
أذهب إلى مراسل الطيران في CNN Pete
Muntean Pete ، هذا شيء
نتعلم عنه للتو ، لذا قل
ما حدث هنا
جيدًا ، Brianna ، هذا هو أول
حادث من هذا القبيل سمعناه على الأقل مثل هذا
، ومن غير المحتمل أن يكون الأخير ،
دعني أطلعك على هذا ، حيث
كانت هناك تغريدة انتشرت في وقت سابق
بعد ظهر هذا اليوم في الساعة 12:30  رحلة الخطوط الجوية الأمريكية
من مطار لاغوارديا في نيويورك
إلى دالاس فورت وورث وفي هذه
التغريدة مقطع فيديو يمكنك فيه سماع
مواجهة تجري في
الخلفية بين مضيفات طيران
مسافرين آخرين وراكب
رفض ارتداء قناع الآن نعرفه من
الأمريكيين  الخطوط الجوية التي غادرت تلك الرحلة في
النهاية ولكن الراكب
تم إقلاعه من تلك الرحلة ويتم الآن
إعادة حجزه
على متن رحلة أخرى لاحظت شركة أمريكان إيرلاينز
أنه عدة مرات  خلال
إجراءاتها المتعلقة بالصعود إلى الطائرة
بمجرد صعودها على متن الطائرة ، يذكرون
الركاب بارتداء قناع ، يأتي هذا في
وقت حرج حقًا لشركات الطيران
عندما يضيفون أسنانًا إلى
سياسات الصاري الخاصة بهم ، United American و
Delta ، الآن جميعهم يقولون إنهم سيفعلون ذلك.
حظر الراكب الذي يرفض ارتداء قناع
من الطيران على تلك الناقل مرة أخرى ، لذلك
لا نعرف في هذه الحالة ما إذا كان هذا
الراكب ممنوعًا ، فنحن نعلم أنه
تم إعادة حجز هذا الراكب ، وهذا
يأتي أيضًا خلال وقت كان فيه
فراغ من اللوائح الفيدرالية  على
شركات الطيران التجارية عندما يتعلق الأمر
بارتداء قناع ، قال مسؤول إدارة الطيران الفيدرالية (FAA)
على التل اليوم إنه يدعم إرشادات مركز السيطرة على الأمراض (CDC)
لكنه توقف عن سن
أي لوائح جديدة في الصناعة التي
تحاول صناعة الطيران فعلاً
فرض هذه السياسة بمفردها
وهناك  قليلا من خليط من السياسات
لا توجد قاعدة فيدرالية حول هذا بعد على الرغم من
بريانا